like a unicorn Frappuccino and a green
tea frappuccino like had a mythical baby
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I think the last time I had a
Frappuccino I was 16
oh whoa the last time I had a proper
[ __ ] Oh was this morning I drink a
caramel Frappuccino every single morning
from Starbucks I love it yeah I needed
to live what's there not to love this is
a sequel to the unicorn Frappuccino it
makes me sad that it's a sequel because
sequels usually are a million times
worse is this gonna be grease too or is
this gonna be Toy Story 3 like you know
you're right yes when I think of Dragon
I think of like fiery hot there's gonna
be Tabasco sauce I think it's gonna be
sriracha
I'm ready for the dragon I can't wait oh
it's like you have to like get down
close this looks like Christmas morning
it looks like I might die of a trinket
which is not my room where the dragon
went anyway it also looks like what
happens after you drink after you look
like rapper - yeah okay I mean there is
some like red pinkish that's gonna be
sriracha we're gonna eat drink yeah it's
gonna burn and I'm gonna cut palladium
extreme for a year okay improv let's get
it okay I'll let you the wall he's a
little too intimate
oh my what it's green tea it's delicious
I love it oh it tastes good grass not
spicy it's a spicy
Jonathan be spicy yeah dragged there it
is I'm all ears
this is so good big goodness I'm gonna
go in for them because it's not too
sweet
okay that's virgin yeah like I feel like
I could drink this whole thing and not
be like crazy for the rest of the day I
feel like a full cup of this is gonna
make
I feel magical drinking like I literally
feel like I just licked the law no no I
don't dislike it like but you feel like
it tastes like dirt I wonder what the
red is on top we have this rubber I
can't identify that yeah I don't taste
any thuds I like cherry or something I
still don't understand why it's called
dragon oh maybe it's dragon because it's
green tea and green tea is Asian like a
green dragon like an Asian dragon like
moo shu from Mulan that would be so the
land it taste like matcha is matcha
another language for grass I'm not
feeling the sugar high right now like
I'm feeling it I just had like three
sips and I'm like whew I kind of feel a
little bit chilly
it's healthy because it's green tea I
think it needs more a character I needed
to be more Dragon s so posted on my
Instagram the taste is there I would
tear out order this what do you think
will be next can we
let's petition I want like an elf one no
that's Christmas
[Music]
you